[Applause]
this is the moment america and women's
rights went back in time
[Music]
[Applause]
50 years after legalizing abortion the
supreme court reversing a constitutional
right for the first time
it is a decision which defines the deep
divides in american life for some cause
for celebration
for others a deeply personal betrayal
i've had an abortion i'll speak about
that openly i was 19 years old i still
sit with the grief of that i stay with
the shame of that it's very nuanced it
doesn't mean if we make that choice it
doesn't mean we're happy about it but at
least we had the opportunity i didn't
have the funding to take care of a child
the way i wanted to i didn't have the
opportunities that a lot of these people
have to take care of their kids
[Applause]
more than half of america's 50 states
will severely restrict all ban abortion
in the coming hours and days
it is a seismic shift which moved angry
lawmakers to march through the capital
this is part of the republican party's
dark vision for america they want to
roll back every possible right that has
been earned over the decades it is an
anti-woman agenda the supreme court has
lost its legitimacy trying to tell women
what to do with their bodies that is
absolutely ridiculous our choice
we're not going back
we're not going to be treated as
second-class citizens and we're dang on
sure not going to be treated as property
an intervention too from the president a
practicing catholic who has wrestled
with his feelings on abortion in the
past this time unequivocal
it's a sad day for the court and for the
country
now with rogue on
let's be very clear
the health and life of women in this
nation
are now at risk
five of these nine supreme court
justices voted to overturn roe versus
wade a 1973 ruling which legalized
abortion to the point of fetal viability
in his opinion justice samuel alito
wrote roe was egregiously wrong from the
start its reasoning was exceptionally
weak and the decision has had damaging
consequences another judge said the
court should reconsider rulings that now
protect contraception and same-sex
marriage
do you worry about same-sex marriage
there was absolutely i absolutely do
i absolutely do worry about same-sex
marriage i worry about um the policing
of all sex acts in general for people
outside america this feels quite
dystopian it is dystopian
it is dystopian
the supreme court hasn't arrived at this
point by accident its newly conservative
composition is the product of political
maneuvering this decision the result of
decades of campaigning by old and young
today is the day we usher in a new era
the united states that protects life
that protects the unborn that supports
women
this is undeniably a new era for america
but others will argue it's a repressive
and regressive move the full force of
which will be felt by women in cities
and states far from here martha kellner
sky news washington